these past few weeks have been a
challenge for everybody of course since
we're in this together we're sharing
some video diaries of Americans
practically practicing social distancing
Val bein Canelo is on the front lines of
the coronavirus fight as a respiratory
therapist from Pennsylvania
Alfonso Oz is getting Niels to people's
doors as a door - delivery driver in
North Carolina Nagy Austin is keeping
people connected as the founder of a
social club for people of color in
Brooklyn and the reveal then the
Reverend Kelly Huff Rogers is reaching
the faithful online as the senior
minister of the Scarsdale New York
Congregational Church were happy they
are all sharing their experiences this
is how my day begins during a corona
virus outbreak a lot of people are
really interested in how companies are
pivoting to sort of meet this weird new
demand that sort of been thrust upon us
[Music]
we are good to go it's okay my anxiety
level is climbing I have to report to
work in two days to the hospital and I
am a respiratory therapist my brothers
are they actually both work in hospitals
so they tell me it's a it's crazy up
there they're on the front line as well
we launched our digital membership site
which is basically all of that those
club rolled up onto an online platform
there's a lot of learning going on I
thought that this would be more of a
time of rest and respite but my brain is
more energized than it is normally
because I'm out of my routine
donar Wolfe said that all non-essential
businesses need to close anything non
life-sustaining
it needs to close are we going to be in
the house next week not allowed out to
the grocery store we don't really know
what's going on our instacart keeps
getting substitutions because there's no
fresh food in the store empty shelves no
toilet paper to be found
and facial tissues no napkins that with
our contractor because we were in the
middle of expanding our clubhouse in
Brooklyn it was your typical
entrepreneurial day at least in my
journey a little different in the fact
of having to build for a future that you
don't necessarily know what to expect as
I was leaving the parking lot area here
that gives me a big thumbs up you know I
kind of pointed at my shirt give me a
thumbs up so people appreciate it I
would say that today everyone's anxiety
level was definitely up I went to target
master
I bought guns and ammo then I went to
the gas station filled up with gas hey
guys I saw a lot of people filling extra
gasoline containers what are you doing
people think that the apocalypse is
happening preparing for the worst
hoping for the best in in truths
humanity's success as a species is
predicated on the survival of the
fittest folks in our congregation are
doing okay
sometimes love looks like leaving you
supplies for needy people on your porch
we are continuing to bring services to
our community and we're continuing to
bring spiritual health and well-being to
our people the kids are definitely
getting bored so a lot of eating Michael
what are you doing Michael what are you
doing Michael what are you doing I
started the morning off getting a coffee
from a place not too far from my
apartment
they had super strict social distancing
rules so as one person at a time that
felt really good to support a local
business just because everything is
super shut down in my neighborhood I
definitely think people should you know
listen to what's going on and I just
blow it off because it's about you you
need to keep yourself you know look
after yourself
but you know what these times these
times right now you got to worry about
the person next to you as well I don't
know how that happened but right before
everything goes on sort of shutdown mode
we're getting a puppy we're so excited
to see him arrive and he's very sweet
and very gentle good Steve good Steven
no Steven
what I've learned so far is that we can
make just about anything work still
healthy everybody's a little cooped up a
little cabin fever E and there's the
puppy crying but I think we got this
so night shift
seven p27 a another hospital there was a
definite increase for sure of people
coming in and there is a shortage of PPE
we're seeing that people have
desperately needed community and a place
to really center themselves and so
they're really finding a lot of solace
in our digital membership where they can
get that which is a really sort of
humbling and and pressure-filled role to
have throughout all of this my
seven-year-old has a fever and is
coughing and is feeling pretty miserable
I prayed that my little guy continues to
get better and that it was just a
unfortunate cold and bad timing but this
has been a really interesting project
and we'll keep you posted you know our
best wishes to the minister her family
and everyone who took the time to share
their experiences with us there were so
many interesting points in there guys
but the one that really struck me was I
think a lot of people thought being
confined to home would be more restful
yeah but it's actually turned out to be
more stressful because our routines are
all so utterly disruptive also out of
whack but you know back to what you were
saying Tony about getting a puppy
now almost is a good time because you're
sitting at home so you can train it you
can train your daughter Kerby and her
fiance Virgil on the list for a Brno
doodle so we hope that that comes
through because they're they're
quarantined at home or there they have
to stay at home because of work and now
is a good time to do all the training I
think that's great but what I liked is
the guy who said people noticed his
medical garb and you know gave him a
special shout-out because we really do
appreciate the job it's a great package
and what it reminds me meeting all those
people is that we are living through a
real moment of history and historians
are gonna look at Diaries like that a
hundred years from now fifty years from
now and and recreate these very unusual
and extraordinary times years from now
we'll have a story to tell our children
and grandchildren just think about that
for a second